dieses Shop Chi Sandwich sollte jeder
von euch kennen und es hat quasi die
gleichen Zutaten wie ein Cheeseburger
das heißt Fleisch cheese Brot und wenn
man möchte Zwiebeln und Paprika wir
nehmen unser Hackfleisch und Braten das
einmal an jetzt kommt auch schon direkt
der Name top cheese ins Spiel denn das
machen wir schön klein wenn unser
Fleisch bisschen Farbe hat geben wir
Zwiebeln und Paprika dazu ihr salzen und
pfeffern das ganze wir nehmen unser Brot
und schneiden es auf aber nicht ganz
sondern es soll sich quasi aufklappen
lassen ungefähr so jetzt kriegen wir
auch die Farbe an unsere Haken soll
richtig schön knusprig werden
karamellisieren jetzt das wichtigste
Sandwich Käse oben drauf das ist der
Kleber der alles zusammenhält Brot
antosten jetzt nehmen wir uns alles und
geben es auf unser Sandwich wenn was
runterfällt naja nicht so schlimm legen
wir es oben drauf zu klappen und
runterladen unglaublich probieren wir
das Ganze also auf jeden Fall ein
richtiger apparello den wir uns hier
gezaubert haben ist es verdammt verdammt
lecker